in case you didn't know we're just going
to remind you mother's day is on sunday
and you know you may still be trying to
decide what to do for mom for the
special day well one of the more
relaxing options of course is to treat
her with a nice spa day so joining us
this morning from the jw marriott las
vegas resort is uh in spa is joni torres
uh with spa aqua is that correct is it
spa aqua are we pronouncing that right
now you guys
you just reopen you have a brand new
look and i know our photographer is
there so kind of tell us about what what
people can expect on the inside now
so we have renovated all of our spa and
salon
so and we also have a barber shop now as
well so we're currently standing inside
of our renovated waiting space so this
is our relaxation room for our couples
when you're getting prepared for your
service we bring you upstairs to this
space that you can relax and just kind
of have a moment um to for yourself
before your treatment begins
we also have our event going on this
weekend so we have our mother's day
event we have some beautiful retail that
we wanted to display that just kind of
shows what's available for you after
your service if you wanted to continue
your take-home care
sounds good it looks beautiful in there
this has got to be one of your biggest
weekends so tell us about some of the
fun specials and they have fun names too
that you've named them right
we do we have an event going on on
saturday the 7th
and we're going to be highlighting our
spatial skin care brand and our body
care brand which is our yonko brand and
so we have three packages that are
available the let it glow package we
have the mommy and mimosa and we have
the like mother like daughter so you
have packages that you can do for
yourself and you have packages that you
can invite yourself or a friend and just
kind of make a day of it on the 7th we
will actually be having mimosas and we
will be having
some food options available while we
have the vendor here to kind of explain
the services and the products for us and
just be able to really celebrate our
moms oh i love that now we're kind of
walking into one of the treatment rooms
here it just looks relaxing already it
sounds perfect music yeah in the spirit
it really does and i love okay mommy and
mimosa that's kind of perfect and
they're having mimosas all right i know
celebrate mom all weekend long
why did you decide to renovate what was
it that inspired the spa to have a new
look
well we definitely we've been around for
over 20 years now so we wanted to be
able to make sure that we stay ahead
of the trends and make sure that we are
providing a great experience and service
for all of our guests when they come to
visit the spa we want you to be relaxed
we want you to be able to really come in
and let go of all of your stresses and
your worries and so you'll see inside of
those treatment rooms all of those
spaces have been renovated we have four
couples rooms now available
and we provide facials massages and body
treatments wow that's perfect sounds
wonderful right in town easy access
joanie thank you so much for being on
the show this morning we appreciate it
enjoy mother's day weekend i'm sure it's
going to be busy but it is fun for moms
so get out there purchase those gift
cards now